Right
crying.
She said,
can you eat pork at home?
I said,
what's a good set?
Okay.
All right.
I'm Kathryn Garcia.
I'm 27 my name is Deanna [inaudible].
I'm 28 years old.
I mean with gasoline for five years.
I would describe our marriage as a godsend and I once in a million opportunity
to be with someone like Dean Dale.
Oh Wow.
They look like a minion.
No,
you're beautiful mania.
Kathleen,
can you hear me?
Kathleen?
Ready?
Do you know?
Um,
it was in Barbados.
We both worked on a cruise ship and I was doing luggage.
She was,
she's an entertainer and that's where I met Barbados.
What was your first impression of her?
The most beautiful girl I've ever seen in my life.
We were working on a cruise ship and I saw Dando and I was like,
oh,
he's cute,
but I got to go.
So then I ran off later that night I went into the restaurant and I saw him
there in his Tuxedo.
I just like had tunnel vision on him and my heart was racing.
I was like,
okay,
God,
what are you trying to tell me?
Like,
why am I so drawn to this person?
I think he said that he was like,
Oh,
who's this new girl on the ship and that he was shy around me.
Is that what you said?
The most beautiful person I've ever seen.
How's your answer?
Yeah.
Oh,
the contract came to an end our first year of dating and I had to leave the ship
and he had to stay.
We were in London and I was so sad because it's her time to go back to America.
DDO had to work that day,
so he got on the taxi with me and then he was like,
I'm going to be late for work.
I have to,
I have to get out.
I said goodbye,
my last goodbye in a taxi and we were both crying and it was just a horrible
goodbye.
I thought that that's going to be the last black time for that,
like contract that out and get to see her.
I was so sad.
I was just in the room like crying and just like crushed.
She felt the same way and she's like,
we can't say our goodbye like this.
Went outside,
hailed a cab,
got in the car,
and then there's still traffic,
get off the cab.
And I was crying and running in a dress and heels and then one of my heels broke
and I was like,
wow,
this obviously I really love this man.
This is crazy.
So I go down,
I run down the stairs,
I bang on the door
and I opened the door and I saw her.
I was like,
oh my gosh,
your hair.
And I just broke down like on my knees crying.
And if that's not love,
I don't know what it is and I know that I'm going to marry her.
That's kind of when I realized like,
wow,
this is something I'm willing to fight for.
I'm willing to lose everything in my life to be with this person.
So Dean and I obviously met on a cruise ship and there's this like stigma with
ship manse's that it's usually just a fleeing.
And,
um,
I actually had my boss bring me into a room when she found out Dean Joe and I
were dating and she said,
I just don't think it's a good idea.
On top of that,
when we left the ships,
dino had to get a visa and he was denied and that was like the most devastating
thing for both of us.
And then we spent both of our life savings on lawyers fees.
Dean Joe left everything to come to America to be with me.
He left his family,
his language,
his culture.
He had to quit his career yet to basically start from scratch.
And I'm,
I can't believe he did that for me.
You only live once and I can't live without her.
I guess when I moved back to go,
go back to the Philippines after my contract,
I'll be with my family and my friends,
but my heart is missing something.
I need to just lay it on the line and trust this love that we have
makes me feel like not guilty,
but I do feel sad.
Um,
because his family is extremely close,
like mine,
they weren't able to be here for our wedding day.
And that like
that's the proof right there of his sacrifice.
They understood that I'm just doing this for love then it's hard,
but it's,
it's all worth it.
I Dunno.
I mean everything's great.
Um,
maybe just cause we want to have kids,
um,
emotionally we are ready financially.
I don't think we're ready.
Uh,
so I think that's like,
we,
we both have baby fever is every time we see children or babies,
but we need to be patient and we need to be smart about this because we want to
provide the best to our future babies.
I think that's it.
If you asked me what's the hardest thing about my career or other aspects of my
life,
I could like give you a huge list.
But Dino's
my constant and my,
my support in life.
I don't think there's anything hard about being with Dino.
Have this thing
you said before that you had problems before.
Like,
no thanks.
Trust,
but I'll always be here so thick and thin,
uh,
till death do us part.
I love Olivia.
I'll,
I loved here.
We're going to tell you why.
Uh,
I can check phones off.
I just wanted to tell you,
thank you for all of your sacrifices and for turning your world upside down to
be with me.
And I know we talk about this a lot,
but this really is like
the best part of my entire life ever and all of the struggles that we faced,
we've gotten through together and you've never once let me down ever,
and you're the best thing that's ever happened to me.
And thank you for finding me and thank you for staying.
I love you.
I'm going to kiss me.
Thank you guys for the free a therapy session
and cut.
Thank you for checking out another episode of both sides in the comments below.
If you think you should be in season three,
if you have a story worth sharing,
uh,
let us know and maybe we'll give you a call.
In the meantime,
subscribe here and watch more videos.
Y'All know the deal.
Peace out.